what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
morning coffee thoughts where I
tell you random things while I drink
coffee before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos
oh God that's so hot that's so hot oh
God
I thought I thought I'm learning to make
chai tea myself instead of buying it and
I don't think I make it right
um it's like still kind of Milky
and I feel like I put a lot of chai tea
in it so I don't know why
maybe it's maybe it's not supposed to
taste as sugary as I like it okay
anyways
so today
I'm going to be talking about whale
attack part two
this week I was harassed my family was
harassed
for talking about whales
now
now
today on Tick Tock a clip was taking
taken of me it was a bit out of context
you know sometimes maybe I make fun of
them a little too hard
but it's like I make fun of everyone I
feel like if you think you're special
you're not you're gonna get made fun of
just like everyone else anyways so
there's a clip of me on Tick Tock that I
said
name a girl that looks good at 300
pounds on the context of this is
a girl after girl will come on my show
and
we just ignore reality
we just live in delusion
okay we live in delusion
and they'll say we'll talk about lizzo
as an example she's just an example of
an overweight woman
and they'll say lizzo's a tent and in
response to this frustrating phenomenon
where as women we can't seem to
acknowledge
that thin girls tend to be prettier and
heavy girls tend to be heavier I said
name one girl that looks good at 300
pounds
now in another clip that was taken out
of context
I said
I can't remember exactly but there's
something along the lines of if you're
overweight you don't deserve a man that
makes six figures
now what they didn't put in that clip is
I don't think anyone deserves
anything when it comes to love you kind
of
you kind of get what you get and you
don't get upset you know what I mean
like
and I don't think an Instagram model
deserves a man that makes six figures
they probably can't get them either they
probably get the same outcome even
though they have the looks but the point
is the looks get you in the door for
most guys that make six figures and
there are some that you know
you might get away with it like Tech
nerds you know like nerdy yeah look it
but the most desired men
have beautiful young women by their
sides and sorry
this is life I don't I don't think I
would qualify
for certain you know guys in that
demographic either it's okay like it's
this is like saying you don't deserve to
be in the NFL
it we really shouldn't be offended by it
now
this proceeded so what happened first
was all the girls that were 300 pounds
would basically take the sound of me
um saying that no one looks good at 300
pounds and said
and then they would just show me
pictures of their blubber I'm like
Ellie stop it stop it my dog
they would just show me pictures of
their blubber and I'm just like
okay you're just proving my point and
then they would like put Instagram
pictures of me
um
and try to say that I was uglier one
Mama guys you you were just proving my
point you're proven my point too and I'm
like okay if your boy is then I don't
deserve a six-figure guy either I would
be like probably not what the [ __ ]
anyways then
they start tagging my ex-boyfriend I
mean like wasn't your ex-boyfriend
overweight and I'm like
you don't need to you don't need to
bring him into this
foreign
starts weighing in on the situation I'm
like y'all
oh my God and then it was like kind of
crazy because all these big creators all
these huge creators start like start
basically calling me ugly and I don't I
didn't actually see most of the videos
it's the crazy thing I just heard about
him later but I was like who cares and
like
and then it's like if you're like all
right guys you can call me ugly but you
know I don't I genuinely don't think I'm
ugly so
you could say that but I'm not I don't
believe it
and then they'll they'll be like well
you're take your L sis like and I'm just
like what
so then part two of this madness part
two is these whales start calling my
mother
they start calling my mother and my
friends from high school and all these
people tell them I'm fat phobic and I'm
just like
you people are crazy like honestly if
you put as much effort that you put into
stalking me
as you put into as you would put into
the gym you might see some progress up
you might
like y'all can call me what you want on
the internet but you can't call me fat
so get it get out get out look it
you could say you could say I could lose
10 pounds and I'll probably agree it's
probably the coffee but yo I deadlift
300 pounds I squat 250.
I run I jump I play Semi-Pro volleyball
you can't tell me I'm fat uh cooked nada
you can I just played a two hour
volleyball game yesterday like nayski
NADA any Ellie stop it stop it
so
so the whales and then they continue so
not only do they call my mother they
call my sister to bully her now mind you
my sister
she don't care
I swear to God you can't guys can't do
anything and then they'll pull up a
quote of me saying some of y'all never
got bullied as a kid and it shows and
sometimes people can't take jokes like
it's like okay let's be funny
um but you know this is some truth like
and this is the thing
my sister was bullied as a child by each
other because as siblings that is your
job to bully each other enough to keep
you humble and she didn't care and she
was just like she was like laughing at
me and then they're trying to say oh my
God this one Tick Tock was like telling
me that I like being bullied and I like
and I like um what do you call it their
roles and they're like yeah she just
wants fat girls to bully her because
it's like a kink I'm like ew stop it
no like
no oh
foreign
yeah anyways so but it's funny though
because the same people
that will screen body positivity will
will shame your body okay they'll be
like they'll say oh you look like you're
pregnant and I'm like okay if if that
was true
but wouldn't it be a good thing because
you guys you guys are for body
positivity so would it wouldn't it be
so then you wouldn't technically be
insulting me
it's like these people and then the same
ones that are like oh you're so mean
they'll do the same thing back to you
and it's like
look it I don't I don't really mind
being made fun of I feel like it's part
of the game I feel like like
okay like call me ugly and you're still
a whale and you're still a whale like I
can't
like I feel like it's part of the game
so I don't I don't really mind that but
it's like it just it shows you the
hypocrisy of these people because it's
like they'll
they'll they'll act like they're the
good guys but like you say anything they
don't like boom
they ski NADA they're they're these
crazy people but oh yeah so they started
harassing my sister they started
harassing my mother they started
my sister my mother
um my brother like they just went in I'm
like
oh they left reviews at my parents
business they sold it so they didn't
really work there anymore but you know
they heard about that and it was funny
though because the whales
they also um what do you call it
they were they were telling my mom she
was a bad mom because I said my mom fat
shamed me as a child and at first at the
time
I it did like I was mad about it and I
had this society that told me like that
was bad and my mom was bad for doing
that and I wouldn't say she wasn't like
like these people were trying to say she
like bullied me or did but it like I
when I was a kid I used to say well I
can't wait to get fat someday like like
to be funny because you know it's my
humor it's my humor don't take this but
and they took this as like I was bullied
into this stuff and like my mom was so
mean but like my mom genuinely cared
about me and I genuinely think if you
let your kid get fat that's child abuse
and my mom didn't and she did everything
in her power to so I didn't have to
struggle with weight the same way that
she did because my mom was fat and if
you do that to a kid you're putting them
in the worst position ever like
minus being in a single parent home like
that is something I would never wish on
a child I've been overweight
for short periods of my life and it's
always something I've had to work at but
no I
that that is a horrible thing to do to a
child and if you have such bad eating
habits that you pass those on to your
kids you are doing something wrong as a
parent you need to fix it because that
is not cool it is not cool to raise your
kid in an environment where they're
going to have to struggle with this
problem their whole life because you
can't control yours and that's why I've
I fight so hard against this stuff and I
work so hard to stay in shape and I'm
always trying to lose that last 10
pounds always trying to lose that last
20 pounds because one day I want to have
children and I don't want to raise them
in an environment
where they struggle with their weight
the same way I did
so shout out to the whales um you're
just making me more famous
um
uh please stop calling my parents though
and my mom they know what I do for a
living they don't care
um shout out
to
my fans who got me through this you know
and shout out to my volleyball team
because we're 1-0 and we just kill it so
shout out
like the video on your way out don't
forget to subscribe I'll talk to you
next time